c'était annoncé les clims et les
ventilateurs vont continuer à tourner
demain Loir-et-Cher et Indre-et-Loire
maintenu en vigilance jaune à la
canicule orange aux orages avec des
températures qui resteront au dessus des
35 degrés en Sud Touraine avant une
baisse sous la barre des 30 degrés
vendredi et si cet épisode de chaleur
est pénible pour tout le monde il est
particulièrement pour les plus fragiles
notamment les 100 domicile fixes comment
affront-ils cette période et bien
heureusement ils ne sont pas seuls à
Tours l'association la barque leur
propose de faire un tour à la fraîche en
bord de Loire vous voyez ce reportage
signé Faustine Luneau avec Clémence
dausques
on va faire un tour de bateau
[Musique]
plus de 34 degrés sur le thermomètre
aujourd'hui alors au café associatif la
barque on part se rafraîchir à
l'extérieur direction la Rabouilleuse
sur les bords de la Loire invité par
l'association Culture du cœur une pause
à l'ombre qui fait du bien à tout le
groupe parmi eux des personnes dans le
besoin et notamment des sans-abris ces
chaleurs canicules où il y a pas
d'oxygène sur le bitume avec les
bâtiments qui sont très rapprochés
les bords de Loire
sous les arbres tant qu'on peut aller
chercher un peu de fraîcheur faut y
aller on est au bord de Loire il y a un
air frais qui passe et ouais ça fait du
bien ça fait quand même deux ans qu'il
est avec moi c'est un oiseau exotique
qui vient d'Australie et il a l'habitude
du beau temps il adore ça et à chaque
fois que je le sors bah il siffle il
chante on est content de cette belle
journée parce qu'il fait super beau et
ben on va profiter de faire du bateau et
moi ça me change
ça me change de la routine
faire rillettes de poulet
un moment partagé loin du quotidien et
qui crée du lien habitué à la ville où
la chaleur n'est pas supportable en
pleine canicule certains découvrent ce
lieu paisible l'occasion de se joindre
au public d'un petit concert de jazz au
bord de l'eau
[Musique]
les sorties comme ça quand on peut
emmener quand même plusieurs personnes
sur l'extérieur ça permet aussi de
désengorger et puis de d'apaiser aussi
tout le monde puis c'est cool aussi fort
de
beaucoup qui restent aussi au
centre-ville qui souffrent la chaleur
tout ça les animaux sur le bitume enfin
c'est horrible donc et qui connaissent
pas du tout les abords de tours alors
que c'est vraiment voilà on a fait 10
minutes de bus et on y était quoi la
suite de la balade qui les attend une
traversée de la Loire à bord de ce petit
bateau à Tours la vague de chaleur
devrait se poursuivre jusqu'à demain